I have a dream that's all I need and I
made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey guys welcome to D LM model
lifestyle I'm Daniel and this is my
brother Adam
hi everyone and this is our third video
of our new series called body
transformation from fat to fit in twelve
weeks last time we covered the first two
weeks of this whole body transformation
and this is how I did so far
about four and a half kilos well done I
have known the first two weeks yeah
thanks Danny Brenda well thanks for the
help man welcome so how do you feel
about this last two weeks uh yeah I
think we made some good progress and we
made some mistakes as well especially in
the nutrition department yeah yeah it's
like someone took some heat Slayer and I
just keep gym and exercise a few times
but overall really go into it you know
so I cut it down and I think right yeah
good progress yeah and ready to go for
hmm all right cool
so how'd a news adapting to this new
healthy lifestyle and so if you're ready
let's head into the third and fourth
weakest it up this whole new
transformation
you ready yeah let's do it all right so
let's have a look at the third and the
fourth week diet plan and the workout
routine now the diet plan is mostly
gonna be the same but the workout
routine that's gonna change a lot so
let's have a look at that first
[Music]
alright so in the first half of the
workout you guys will do heat Acharya
the first day will be on the treadmill
the second day on the bicycle and the
third day is gonna be on the rowing
machine and then you just repeat the
same order for the fourth the fifth and
the sixth day now when you do the cardio
workouts you will do the treadmill the
bicycle and the rowing machine in the
same way as you did it in the last two
weeks so you're gonna warm up for three
minutes and then you do the rest of the
workout by going fast and a heart for 30
seconds and then you're gonna rest for
30 seconds and then you just repeat it
until the time is up the only difference
now is that instead of working out for
15 minutes you will do it for 20 all
right we could he just started and
Theresa had his wife is also joining him
for the workouts so these dolls are
going to do this weight loss competition
all right so the cardio is the same as
the first in the second week so I don't
know and Theresa is just gonna warm up a
little bit just do three minutes on the
treadmill then they're gonna change to
30 seconds hard and fast and 30 seconds
of rest but because Hannah's doing this
weight-loss competition we're gonna
start with intervals today as well so
he's gonna do 30 seconds hard and fast
then 30 seconds of rest and then 30
seconds of interval we're gonna put the
treadmill all the way to level 15 now
any other half the workout we will focus
on weight training and we will move away
from the circuit you will do your upper
body muscles under one day and your legs
and abs on the other day then you just
alternate between these two workouts for
the next two weeks so on day one you
will do the upper body you will do bench
press and you're gonna do four sets of
ten
next is a back deck four sets of ten
[Music]
Nexxus triceps with rope you're gonna do
four of ten
next up rope bicep curls
[Music]
next the military shoulder press
[Music]
[Applause]
next is the lab pulled out four sets of
ten
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and lastly you're gonna do push-ups if
it's too hard for you gonna do the
push-ups on your knees and you're gonna
do three sets until your muscles fail
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's go today - first
you're going to do the heat cardio on
the bicycle and after that you're gonna
do your legs and your abs so first is
the leg prep so you can do four sets of
ten
[Music]
Max is a comprises 4 sets of 12
[Music]
next up leg extensions four sets of ten
next up hamstring curls or set of ten
all right next up we're going to do
three ABS exercises the first exercise
is going to be the butterflies and
you're going to do three sets of ten
[Music]
next up is the bicycles three sets of
ten
[Music]
and lastly is going to be ab crunches
three sets of ten
[Music]
all right so that's it for the workout
routine so let's have a look at the diet
plan now the diet plan is mostly gonna
be still the same it's still based on a
model of diet plan video that is on my
channel if you guys missed it go and
check it out all that before you in the
video description as well but a change
that we're gonna bring in this week is
no more cheat meals or snacks because
it's time to learn how to adapt this new
healthy lifestyle and to choose healthy
delicious snacks instead of unhealthy I
don't know how do you feel about that
well you know we're going hardcore now
know what we're gonna do is learn to
make healthy healthy snacks and meals
instead and we've started doing that and
it's actually cry 2 now in the past you
know we would really just make some mac
and cheese and chuck it down because we
need to eat nice or eat something nice
and go for extra cheesy but now that
we're doing is really getting into new
recipes and stuff and making delicious
meals actually all kinds of spice and
herbs and stuff and really looking at
what is out there and so on so healthy
meals but delicious eaten bites you put
a lot of effort in it and you know what
you put in is what you're gonna get out
so that protein you recognize this is
probably Nani this is going to make me
you exercise water and so on so yeah now
we really were ready to cut out the
unhealthy snacks and we've really
started making this change to it towards
not healthy food just but delicious
delicious healthy really working on it
making making food a thing yeah yeah man
I'm probably I hope you guys are
abducting to this healthy lifestyle in
the same kind of way so how do you feel
about the change that we brought in how
do you feel about this workout your team
and the diet plan for the next two weeks
yeah so really looking forward to it for
the nutrition we've just been getting
so you know that diet that the balance
of how much you need to eat right so if
you eat that extra piece of of toast
that you don't need to or that extra
piece of chicken or whatever it's it
also kills that gang so we're really
getting into just eating just enough
just enough yeah so like Henry's not
gonna eat like a guy who's weighing at
100 kilos but now he's gonna eat like a
guy who's weighing in at 80 kilos right
yeah all right so let's fast-forward
let's show you guys how how many did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
riy lost just over three kilos how do
you feel yeah wow that was good yeah
so getting they did you know actually
feel better you know I feel a bit
lighter no I think my stats have gone
off strength and agility
my so yeah but now I feel lighter but
faster you know stronger mmm
I feel much better and you know some of
the old man aches and pains I've gone
away some of them Wow
so one yeah used to struggle you know
you get out of it but almost can jump
out of it so nothing really feel much
better and yeah looking forward to what
we can achieve in the next two weeks
yeah huh and that's that's the change
you feel just okay kilos already and
there's still a few weeds left yeah let
us know how you guys did down below and
if you liked the video give us a thumbs
up subscribe and click the notifications
out so you won't miss the next video and
that's it show you guys
[Music]